in the pantheon of inspirational sports
movies it's no secret that the rocky
franchise stands head and shoulders
above the rest but how did the Italian
stallion go from underdog to champion to
boxing trainer here's the entire Rocky
story explained in rocky our hero is
plucked out of obscurity by heavyweight
champion Apollo Creed who offers rocky a
whopping 150 thousand dollars to take
him on
but he wasn't counting on was rocky
having more heart than anyone else in
the game well rocky trains for the
fights he falls in love with Adrian the
sister of Rocky's pal pallie rocky also
befriends Mickey gold mill a
tough-as-nails boxing trainer who whips
the Italian stallion into shape although
rocky ultimately loses the fight he gets
the girl and the respect of the boxing
community and Apollo promises that there
won't be a rematch that promise doesn't
last long
rocky too sees Rocky Balboa forced to
ignore Apollo's request for a rematch
when he learns that fighting again could
mean permanent blindness thanks to his
rise to fame rocky finally gets a little
money to his name this allows him to
propose to Adrian who reveals she's
pregnant shortly after their wedding
despite offers for more professional
fights Apollo becomes obsessed over hate
mail about his match with Rocky he goads
the stallion into a rematch which rocky
reluctantly accepts after struggling to
find other employment after the birth of
his child Robert rocky fights Creed and
wins just like that Rocky Balboa is the
new heavyweight champion of the world
five years after taking the Heavyweight
Championship from Apollo Rocky's life is
pretty different
after ten successful title defenses
rocky is rolling in the dough and about
to retire when a young fighter named
James clubber Lang accuses him of taking
easy title fights Micky reveals that
Lang is right about his fights being
hand-picked prompting rocky to accept
Lang's challenge before their big fight
Lane confronts rocky backstage and
shoves Mickey causing the old man to
have a heart attack rocky loses the
championship fight but lets Mickey
believe that he won and the boxing
trainer dies peacefully backstage after
witnessing the loss - clubber Creed
takes rocky to LA and teaches him to
fight using a different style of boxing
with Apollo's help Rocky finds the eye
of the tiger and defeats Lang in a
rematch
in 1985 a Russian boxer named Ivan Drago
battles Apollo Creed in an exhibition
that results in the highly trained
Russian killing Creed in the ring won in
revenge rocky challenges Drago to a
fight which takes place in Russia a
grieving Balboa is accompanied by Paulie
and Duke Apollo's former trainer over
time Duke solidifies himself as one of
Rocky's best trainers getting the
champion back into shape with a fierce
training regimen
after a hard-won fight the Italian
stallion knocks Drago out in the 15th
round right in front of the Soviet
premier rocky 5 finds a champion
struggling with retirement and
fatherhood mismanaged finances has led
to the balboa family losing their riches
and rocky learns that he's got a major
brain injury forcing him to lay down the
gloves rocky reopens Mickey's gym and
lives vicariously through a young
up-and-comer named Tommy Gunn
unfortunately the fulfillment he gets
out of training Gunn causes rocky to
neglect his real son it's up to Adrienne
and Paul II to ground rocky and show him
what's important
after a stunning betrayal by Gunn rocky
focuses on fatherhood and wins back the
affection of his son
Thanks culminates in a brutal street
fight with Tommy after he punches Paulie
in the face rocky takes Tommy on in the
streets and sends a young champ packing
after beating Tommy Gunn rocky
disappears from the boxing world and
opens an Italian restaurant however the
biggest change in his life is the death
of his beloved wife Adrienne from cancer
Rocky's life changes after ESPN
broadcasts a computer-simulated fight
between an in his prime rocky and the
new heavyweight champion Mason the line
Dixon after the simulated fight inspires
rocky to get back into boxing Dixon's
promoters smell an opportunity to pit
the two against each other and a charity
exhibition in Las Vegas
rocky goes toe to toe with Dixon and
manages to go the distance with a young
fighter in the end the bout goes to a
split decision rocky fights hard but
ultimately Dixon is declared the winner
Adonis Donnie Johnson is born the
product of an extramarital affair
between his mom and Apollo Creed years
later after being raised by Apollo's
wife Adonis is ready to follow in his
dad's footsteps and become a boxer
however when no one in California will
train him he goes to Philadelphia to
seek out rocky much like rocky was
picked from obscurity by Apollo Adonis
is picked by the current champion Pretty
Ricky Conlan as his last fight before
prison sentence while Creed and rocky
trained for the match Balboa reveals
he's been diagnosed with cancer
at first rocky refuses to seek treatment
but Adonis encourages him saying he
won't bite unless rocky fights so Balboa
decides the battle is cancer his young
Creed trains to fight the champion in
Liverpool in the fight Creed struggles
against this opponent but he simply
refuses to go down just like his new
mentor he loses the match by decision
but ends up winning the respect of the
crowd in the boxing community in 2018
three years after Adonis is lost from
the first film he becomes a champion
with rocky at his side
just when Adonis's career is taking off
Ivan Drago returns with his son Victor
to challenge him and unfocused Adonis
loses to the fierce contender but spends
the movie preparing for a rematch
ultimately Drago ends up throwing in the
towel on his sons fights after realizing
he's been neglecting his son's health
for boxing
his sacrifice inspires rocky to head to
Vancouver to reconcile with his
estranged son while Creed visits his
father's grave with his family check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]